Apple did a killer job at their
September event announcing the new
iPhone 15 lineup and some other products
but there are some things that they
conveniently did not mention both good
and bad that can affect which phone
you're going to want to buy or maybe
even buy an older iPhone instead so make
sure to pay attention the first thing
they didn't mention is the fact that the
new iPhone 15 pros come with eight
gigabytes of RAM now typically the pros
have had more RAM than the regular
iPhones but last year with a 14 series
all of them came with the same six gigs
of RAM but this year if you spend the
extra money you'll be able to have more
background applications open and save
yourself from getting Auto close
applications which could be frustrating
number two is the new 5G chip in the
iPhone 15 and 15 pros this is qualcomm's
x70 modem which has been updated from
last year now the top speed is
theoretically the same as the x65 but
the real world performance should get
better in what's even more important is
it's going to have better reception so
if you have areas you where you have
very low signal or maybe no signal at
all these new iPhones are going to
improve on that and that is really
helpful and with number three we are
getting into a bunch of camera details
that are important that first one is
that the iPhone 15 Pros actually have
the same exact cameras as the iPhone 14
Pros Apple spent a bunch of time showing
off what they can do but the
improvements are actually all processing
and with that the smaller size iPhone 15
Pro that 3x telephoto it is actually
three years old now and for number four
the 48 megapixel that is now in the
iPhone 15 is actually a new and more
advanced sensor than the reused one that
is coming with the 15 Pros now it is
slightly smaller but has a bunch of new
technology and we'll have to see how it
compares to the 48 megapixel in the 15
Pro and if apple is going to allow it to
be better or limited so if you guys want
to see those tests make sure you guys
click that subscribe button down below
as for number five on stage Apple
mentioned that we are going to be able
to get 24 megapixel images out of the
new iPhone 15s which give you better
quality but they actually save on file
space what they did not say is the heif
max mode that is also available for the
iPhone 15 so yes you will be able to
take full 48 megapixel images where some
Android phones they have big sensors but
they will not allow you to save that
because of their Hardware so you'll be
able to get 48 megapixels just like you
can on the pro phones check out this
amazing new charging system from our
partner Mouse this is their most
advanced wireless charging ecosystem
ever with two times faster charging
speeds thanks to the official Max Leaf
module from Apple it's fully modular so
you can choose what works best for you
or expand your charging setup later
thanks to the magnetic Pogo connections
so no need for cables they have built-in
heatsinks to prevent overheating and
USBC out for charging other devices and
these work great with a mouse case or
with macsafe iPhones and with three
premium finishes to choose from you can
upgrade your charging experience at the
link in the video description for number
six Apple did not mention the zoom
capabilities of the iPhone 15 with the
four teens and previous you were stuck
at only 5x where the Android competition
did way better even without a telephoto
camera but now we found out that you can
go all the way up to 10x on this new 48
megapixel sensor and even though you are
twice as close the quality should still
be better than it was previously for the
next one number seven that is the iPhone
15's Zoom capability we have that new 5x
telephoto instead of 3x but now instead
of maxing out at 15 times Zoom you can
go up to 25 times zoom and the quality
looks surprisingly good from what I've
seen as for number eight Apple showed
off being able to take much better
portrait shots with the iPhone 15 but
they did not mention that you will be
able to use the new 2x mode for portrait
shots previously Apple limited it to 1x
you couldn't even Zoom if you were in
portrait mode and that meant that you
can get some distortions at times and it
just did not look great well now based
on the pictures they shared you could
tell portrait mode is enabled and that
is going to be a really nice upgrade for
regular iPhone purchasers and for number
nine Apple made a big deal about how
these new phones are going to be able to
get portrait shots out of regular photos
so you don't have to go into portrait
mode because it's going to save that
data well now we know that older iPhones
the iPhone 14 pro will be able to do
this as well you can actually take
images that are stored in your camera
roll and add the portrait effect and
that is awesome that's one reason why
you might not need to upgrade because
you're gonna have that in your older
phone with that for number 10 the 24 and
48 megapixel heif shots are also coming
to the iPhone 14 pro this is my biggest
complaint because the photos that were
stored were 12 megapixel and if you
wanted 48 you had to shoot with Pro raw
which gave you massive image sizes and
then you had to convert those later as a
pain but they are bringing this new mode
to the iPhone 14 pro once again that is
awesome for number 11 Apple mentioned G2
standard for wireless charging and apple
actually opened up their Max 8 design to
be able to use with other phones but
what they didn't say is that it is still
limited to 7.5 Watts nobody was
expecting this we thought that you would
get 15 watts on third-party Chargers I
would love to be able to get my Tesla
wireless charging pad to be able to get
my full performance but apple is still
limiting this and that is terrible
number 12 is the display support on
these new iPhones now we have USB type-c
which is really nice but a big upgrade
that came with that is the ability to
connect a cable directly from your phone
to your TV or a monitor and get a 4K 60
HDR out previously you were limited to
just regular 1080p now you can also use
their 69 USB type-c adapter which gives
you power in HDMI out as well as USB if
you want to connect with HDMI and you'll
get really good quality video the next
one has got to do with the new roadside
assistance feature that they showed off
of course with the iPhone 14 lineup we
got satellite SOS for emergencies and
that was cool but roadside assistance is
going to be something that people are
going to use way more often and it made
it seem like that is something that's
coming with just the new iPhone 15s but
that is actually available for the 14
series as well and that is a nice thing
that they're not limiting it moving on
to 14 this is Wi-Fi 6E now it was a
quick little blip on the screen but they
didn't talk about it and Wi-Fi 6E
support helps you to get really good
speed it's actually faster and it helps
with congested areas if there's a lot of
houses around you with Wi-Fi you can
have slowdowns now I tested a Wi-Fi 6E
router previously with the new MacBooks
I got Wi-Fi 6C and one interesting thing
is even if you don't have Wi-Fi 6E you
actually get much better Wi-Fi range and
speed even with your regular router so
that's going to help everybody on these
new phones and number 15 is thread
support for smart devices this is
briefly flashed on screen they didn't
talk about it but thread is a mesh
Network for smart devices that improves
connectivity and responsiveness and it
allows for Direct Control now some home
pods and Apple TV have them but this is
actually the first phone that is coming
with it and that means you can control
your smart devices without internet or
even a Wi-Fi network and even if your
power goes out if you have some battery
enabled smart devices you could still
have direct control which is really nice
and for number 16 not only is there no
rumored red titanium iPhone 15 Pro but
there is not even a red iPhone 15 which
I absolutely loved and that also means
that there is no product red iPhone this
year that supports Charities now Apple
has donated over
270 million dollars from their product
red products and when buying one on the
order page they distinctly set it apart
and they give you other information
about it but it looks like they are not
doing that anymore with this new lineup
and now I'm going to touch on a couple
other interesting things for 17 both the
series 9 and the ultra 2 Apple watches
now have doubled the storage up to 64
gigabytes they did not mention this I
don't know why but you do have more
storage if you like to store a lot of
music podcasts or other things on your
Apple watch and for 18 replacing your
Apple watch battery just got about 25
percent more expensive now I don't know
why they would do this other than just
to help bump you up a little bit to
spend extra money on a new Apple watch
instead of getting a new battery in your
old one for number 19 this one is super
cool you can now charge your Apple watch
or your airpods with the iPhone 15s USB
type-c port now they could be locking it
down just to those devices since there's
no mention of charging another phone or
they could just be limiting it to low
wattage since even the Ultras only
charge at 5 watts and then that won't
drain that much of your battery because
the capacities are pretty small but we
will find out once we get them and for
number 20 the airpods Pro 2 the Apple
showed off with the USB type-c connector
are not actually the same as the
lightning Port airpods Pro 2. these ones
actually support 20 bit 48 kilohertz
lossless audio with four hours of
playback in that mode when connected to
the Vision Pro so if you're going to
want lossless you have to get these new
ones they're not the same and with that
they are actually now rated ip54 for
dust resistance for both the earbuds and
the charging case so even though they
look identical they are not and that
brings me to 21. Apple's 19 USB type-c
earpods are also not just the old one
with lightning but now with the USB
type-c connector they're actually
equipped with a digital to analog
converter that also supports lossless
audio now I haven't used those in years
I don't know what the sound quality is
like if that's even going to be useful
but they put in the effort to put a nice
dag inside of there and for only 19
bucks and for number 22 with the new
airpods Pro 2 with USB type c you
actually cannot buy that case separately
like we have in previous years when
Apple added wireless charging to airpods
you can buy the case separately when
they added Max save charging to airpods
Pro you can also buy that separately
that was nice because you're getting a
fresh battery in there you're getting
rid of scratches but this year they are
not allowing you to do so at all meaning
most likely the new earbuds the actual
earbuds themselves and the airpods case
are both updated now for number 23 Apple
made a huge deal this year about
environmental impact they got rid of
leather showing off their new cases and
how that is kind of the future and the
interesting thing is even though they
showed off or maza's new bands that are
not made from leather and that they're
still partnering with them Hermes is
actually still selling leather bands now
at first I thought that's just bands
that anybody could sell and you could
just buy but that's not the case you can
actually go onto their website and order
an Apple Watch series 9 with the whole
packaging and the leather band including
the exclusive Hermes watch faces that
means the apple is working with them
directly selling in the apro Apple
watches having them do their own
packaging and they're okay with them
still making leather even though Apple
made such a big Point against it and
that reminds me of 2020 when Apple
removed the 5 watt charging bricks from
Apple watches also stating that this is
meant for the environment to help out
but then Hermes was still giving fiber
charging bricks with their apple watches
that you buy from them straight from the
Apple Store and people made a fuss about
this kind of hypocrisy and then Apple
ended up moving it so even though
Apple's switching from leather they're
still clearly fine with leather as long
as you don't buy it on their website so
there you guys go there are 23 things
that Apple did not mention at their new
event let me know what surprised you the
most is it the great features for the
iPhone 15 or the extra features for
older iPhones or something else go and
click that Circle above check out the
mouse cases down below using the link
check out one of those videos right over
there and I'll see you in the next one
foreign